what's up valuetainers
my name is adam sosnick
this is valuetaining questions
what's up value tamers this value tamers
and this is value that i messed up
what's up valuetainers my name is adam
sosnick and this is valuetaining
questions with the personal finance
expert let's talk money
the best financial decision i ever made
was understanding that there's a bigger
picture when it comes to your career and
basically going from having jobs to
having a career i've done a bunch of
different jobs
that
the money wasn't the biggest
motivational factor it was about having
fun and doing what i wanted to love
which is great pursuing a passion but
once i basically said all right i've had
all my fun by age 27 i said now i got to
focus on making money and i started
focusing on sales relationships
networking that enabled me to start
making some serious dough now i'm here
with valuetainment the whole point of
saving that money and living
thriftfully and is that so when you go
out on a date you can actually have a
good time and not be like oh my gosh i
can't believe she ordered the steak this
is crazy if you actually like the other
person like the girl in this case
have a great time you know split a
bottle of sake whatever maybe you don't
spend too much money on liquor just
that's some
minor advice but ball out on your date
the worst financial decision was getting
married
to someone that i met
in the club popping bottles at club live
in south beach shout out to you guys
taking care of this girl and having fun
and
paying for whatever she wanted
that was a pretty bad financial decision
but the best financial decision i made
part of that was having a prenup so when
the relationship didn't work out
sayonara we're all good but i didn't
have to give up half my assets to
someone that didn't work out with a
relationship so people think i'm insane
because i don't have i haven't had a car
in 10 years nobody thinks someone's
insane uh in new york
they don't have a car well people think
i'm freaking out of my mind on not
having a car in miami but when you live
in downtown miami it's essentially like
living in new york you can uber wherever
you want you can walk to wherever you
gotta go
uh and you save so much money not having
a car payment not having insurance not
having gas tickets tolls maintenance
repairs all that and when you can save
that money that's when you can invest
that money
what's on your playlist it depends on
the time of day in the morning i'm
waking up to beethoven and then i'll get
into some
more
edm throughout the day bieber uh justin
timberlake pop type stuff when i go to
the club we're going to hit up some uh
some future from some drake travis scott
um and then at night chill mode more
sinatra
french classical i'm all over the map
bts as well shout out to nancy is there
is there any reason why you would uh
love destiny's child
the number two member of that group
kelly rowland uh we did slow dance one
night at a wedding and um
that girl is mine
anything you want to say to kelly if
she's watching this
kelly why don't you return my text my
calls uh yeah you put a
you know a stay away order what's that
called the restraining order it's fine
we'll figure it out
what's the sexiest accent but of course
a french accent
it's i have a good friend man named
patrice he's starring in major
films these days
jean-jacques
there's nothing more sexy than french
accents if you could have dinner with
any historical figure who would it be
and why
oh
um
this is probably i'm jewish so you would
expect me to be like you know moses
abraham
i won't have dinner with jesus
he can turn water into wine i just want
to be like just dude tell me the truth
bro like i get it like just you know the
virgin mary like just what happened
uh not even religious just bro to bro i
just want to
just want to hear what you got going on
jesus
what i love most about cats is they are
more affectionate than you would think
that they are
and i love the fact that i can go travel
for a long weekend for three days and
leave them food water and you know
whatever they need to do their business
and i don't have to freaking think about
them for 72 hours i come home they're
like sup bro welcome back i don't got to
take them on a walk nothing
so it's like
a lot of the affection with
a tenth of the work of a dog
the craziest thing to me is like when
you're on a boat with someone you're
having a great day and she's like i
gotta go i gotta i gotta go walk my dog
it's like we're in the bahamas on a on a
yacht and you gotta go walk your dog
like get a dog walker go get a cat
so
it's just a lot of work for a dog
the office or it's always sunny
the office always sunny
it's always sunny or the first prince of
bel-air
[Music]
always sunny
it's always sunny or martin
my aunt i love martin in the 90s that
would have been my jam
these days my favorite show is always
sunny shout out to frank reynolds good
friend of mine good friend of the show
window or aisle uh aisle no no window
window i wanna i wanna control the sun
that's coming in and out there's nothing
worse than sitting in a plane and like
there's one window up and the sun is
glaring it's the guy across you're like
yo bro what's up with the window and
just
control
do you sing in the shower oh all the
time
what are you singing dude it's
everything it's um
all we talk is money all we talk is
money these days i'm on a do a leaper
kick
if you don't want to see me try dancing
with somebody
all right i don't know why but i think
dua lipa is like the hottest chick
around yeah i agree is it okay to take
your shoes off on a plane
yeah
for sure at japanese restaurants for
sure at ocd people's houses and
if you need to take it off on a plane
you take it off on a plane but it's more
important to control the window
what's your favorite cartoon character
probably peter griffin
or stewie griffin
or brian or
quagmire
quack giggity
[Laughter]
uh valuetainers thanks for watching this
um
i get a lot of love on certain stuff i
do i get a lot of hate on certain stuff
i do um people can question uh what you
say but don't let people question who
you are that's probably the most
important thing to understand is that
the no matter what you're doing whether
it's social media whether it's work
related whatever you're always going to
have supporters and you're always going
to have haters
and it's okay to listen to the good
stuff or the bad stuff
but just make sure that you have a
moral compass of what you know you want
to be doing and where your direction you
have going on in life and just
freaking go for it don't let anybody
tell you what you can or cannot do or
who you are and
that's not saying that you can't change
perspectives or
you know methodologies or what you got
going on but
be your own north star
[Music]
you